what is subplot
um what is subplot um
i would say i would say a true subplot
is any um is any plot separate from
or plot line separate from the a story
that has its own sort of
goal and uh through line right so a
through line is going to be created by
the pursuit of a goal
so it could be your protagonist with
another goal that they're trying to
pursue
i guess maybe the most common example
that we could pull up would be
you know your character is trying to rob
a series of banks
and then there's a romantic subplot so
he's also trying to have a romantic
relationship with someone
that has nothing to do with the banks
right it's its own goal that has its own
arc through the movie
um so i would call that a true subplot
you could also have a
subplot that's driven by another
character so your protagonist is robbing
a
series of banks unbeknownst to him or or
known to him uh his brother
is trying to win custody of his child
right so
separate goal separate it's going to
have its own arc in the story
probably won't have equal weight that's
why we call it a subplot right because
you want your focus to be on the a story
but it'll have its own there's a
separate
goal that's being pursued that has its
own through line
why do we need subplot um i think you
could argue that
not all stories not all movies need
subplots right like sometimes we watch
movies and it
sort of feels like everything is just
connected to that a story and we don't
really have
separate true subplots um
but i think depending on the effect that
you're trying to achieve
and the sort of takeaway message that
you're trying to give with your story
sometimes a subplot can complement that
so
i'm trying to think of a good example i
feel like um
in jerry maguire yeah right like the rod
tidwell
getting his getting his new offer from
the team or whatever
it's been a while since i've seen the
movie but i feel like that was a true
subplot because it was
um if i remember right it was jerry
trying to get an offer for his for his
client right so it would have been jerry
jerry's sort of separate goal is that
right
gosh now i don't remember and i think he
really needed rod didn't he because he
was like his biggest client
yeah just kind of a stakes thing yeah
now i'm getting now i'm confusing myself
i'm not sure if that's right but i think
that's true so i think the subplot was
he's trying to get a deal or an offer
for rod tidwell from
um from arizona right his current uh his
current team
that subplot was necessary
to jerry maguire's story because it um
it complemented his learning that lesson
of the theme which is
that you have to play with with heart
right you have to like
stop being calculated and strategic
sometimes and just
put your whole heart into it right um so
i think that you can look at subplots as
helping to
again teach your protagonist the lesson
that they need to learn from this series
of events
so jerry gets fired and he um he starts
his own company
and um his romance with dorothy i think
is a subplot right because that's a
separate goal he's
having a they're they they very much
overlap and
a lot of times they happen in the same
scenes right where there are these two
plot lines being pushed forward at the
same time um but
starting his business and and making it
a success gosh now that i'm thinking
about it the red tid will thing might be
part of that
and then the subplot of the romance
would be
would be a separate um storyline that
would be the romantic subplot that he's
pursuing
sure yeah i guess so i mean can so can a
film have many subplots or do they oh
they can't okay
yeah yeah oh i definitely think so um
and i think that
um how much weight a subplot has
can vary greatly like you can have you
know
a romance subplot that actually is
nearly equal with the a story
um or you can have something that ends
up looking like sort of a runner through
your script where it's like
maybe it is a minor goal that the
character is pursuing but we only need
to see
three or four scenes where it's like
introduced pursued and then accomplished
or whatever so
um i think you can have lots of subplots
um
my caution about having subplots would
be
just be careful that our focus stays on
the a story
because if you have too many subplots it
can
if you have too many subplots and you're
not um keeping our focus
on that main storyline like that main
conflict that we're watching right
um it can end up feeling like we don't
know which story we're supposed to be
paying attention to
uh it can feel sort of scattered so
that's the only thing i would say
be careful of but most people are when
they come at writing a screenplay they
have a pretty good sense of like what's
that main story that they're trying to
tell
well because is is it dorothy is the is
the renee yeah
okay because she has her own subplot in
that and i don't even know if you'd call
it that but that
she's living with her sister and her
sister i guess it's like a divorcee and
older and maybe a little more bitter
and the great scene of like renee
and tom coming into the women's group
and kind of like
they all just shoot these daggers at
time you know and he's trying to prove
that he's a good guy
yeah and and and and against all odds
like he is a good guy and that
she has this sister character who's real
doubtful and just trying to fight
against that so you see
renee and her situation and i don't know
if that's also a subplot
well so i would i would say that you
could look at the subplot
so renee zellweger i think dorothy has
her has
um the romance subplot we look at it
from her point of view as well
right so we actually see that
relationship from both points of view
i would say that her relationship with
her sister
is just a relationship and it's not its
own subplot because they're not
renee isn't necessarily pursuing
anything
i don't think her sister is either there
there isn't really a goal that
that we're sort of seeing the goal
established and then seeing them pursue
it and conflict and then
resolution right so i would say it's
just a
i would call that a relationship with a
supporting character
um and i would say that that supporting
character uh
is is one of the benefits of the sister
is that she
helps she helps dorothy reflect on like
what she really wants in life
the you know the um the sort of role of
love
in her life and how much she needs how
much she's willing to settle for right
which is
kind of in that same thematic umbrella
you